hey what's up guys alright I like to
start these things kind of slow as we
let the video populate and get into
people's feeds and let you guys jump in
over here obviously for all of these
live streams that I've done for patreon
we usually were doing them or for the
years that we've been doing them we were
doing them behind the patreon wall so
the link was only going out to patrons
and patrons were asking me questions and
we weren't making these public to
everybody
last month we decided to make them
public to everybody but only patrons
could ask me questions so this obviously
is going out to my my full feed so
actually we're about to cross 900,000
subscribers I think today probably so
I'm psyched about that I there's a ton
of stuff I'm super psyched about at the
moment
that being said we've got a lot to talk
about related to the the sargon of akkad
patreon situation and sort of the
subsequent fallout from that and where
that leaves a whole bunch of us
business-wise where it leaves what I'm
doing with you guys and everything else
so I'm gonna take plenty of questions
here and I'm gonna be as open and honest
with you about what I'm going through
right now and what I think this sargon
banning needs in the wider world of
platforming and deep platforming and the
rest of it and sort of what I'm thinking
my future should be related to all of
this and how we can keep doing these
things and and keep them hopefully fan
funded but that there's a lot of other
options and that generally just what the
hell is going on right now so okay so
let me just start slowly with what
happened if you don't know what happened
here let me tell you what's going on if
you've been under an Internet Rock for a
couple days about five or six days ago
sargon of akkad who's a big youtuber has
about eight hundred thousand subscribers
he's been doing it for a long time was
banned on patreon now quickly for those
of you that don't know Sargon at all
Sargon when I started years ago let's
say five years ago when I started really
realizing that something was rotten on
the left and I saw how that was so
connected to free speech and then I saw
the rise of these social justice
warriors
who were hysterical and wanted to
silence everybody and then I started all
of this was leaking into what I saw was
happening the progressive movement when
I started talking about that on YouTube
everybody was saying you've got to go
talk to Sargon of Akkad you've got to
talk to him he is the guy that has been
sounding the alarms on this thing you
got to talk to him anyway I did end up
talking to him on his channel and I tell
you that because he was sort of the
first one of the Liberals that was like
guys what's going on with us we're not
acting liberal anymore and then of
course that leads to everything that
I've talked about over these couple
years right like the left is no longer
liberal the progressives have purged
their free thinkers and it's become an
authoritarian movement that is against
liberalism which is rooted in the
individual and and live-and-let-live act
to you okay so Sargon is not a nobody
he's not just some random youtuber he's
actually been in this studio I've
interviewed him his name's Carl Benjamin
you might be interested in finding it
out
Erik Weinstein had an interesting
comment on Carl that he told me the
other day he said he's sort of a
blue-collar intellect which i think is
actually a great compliment it's like he
doesn't he's not a pure intellectual
like you know that is that has studied
at all of these universities for years
and years am I not to become a professor
and the rest of it published off there
etc but he knows these ideas in and out
but he's blue-collar and that he's a
regular guy he's a bit of an admitted
troll he likes fighting with people
online he loves me makers he was sort of
born out of gamergate
all of those things okay the point is
the guy is not a racist and here's what
happened or as far as I know the guy is
not a racist but let me tell you why he
got banned he was banned because patreon
found a video a few days ago from ten
months ago from February of this year on
another Channel not even his channel
where he was being interviewed over
audio with someone and the guy's not a
native English speaker so there's a
little bit of stilted conversation and
Sargon says the n-word he says it at
least twice now he was saying it because
he was trying to use the language of the
alt-right against them he was mocking
their use and their the way they think
about certain people based on the color
skinned okay so I even said so now let
me back up for a second so when I found
out that Sargon got banned I immediately
texted jack conte who is the CEO of
patreon and I've had Jack in this studio
okay right across from me where this
computer is basically he sat there and
that was when lauren southern was banned
and and jack conte said that we do not
ban people over speech we ban people
over manifest observable behavior m.o be
mob you can't make that up people mob
okay that's what they ban people over
mob behavior irony yeah what is that's
not even I already it's so ridiculous
it's not even our anyway he used my
platform to say what his company's
policy were and they were not about
banning people over speech also he had
made a point of saying and it is in
their Terms of Service that it has to be
an infraction that occurs on their
platform so in this case not only did
Sargon not say the word on their
platform it wasn't even on his YouTube
channel that he's promoting them for
patron patreon right it was on someone
else's channel a small channel with like
4000 subscribers in this case so this
one against all the Terms of Service
they booted him without any warning and
no chance of Appeal or anything like
that and people are seriously pissed
right now and I get why they're pissed
I'm pissed and on all the last three
days I mean this basically I've had a
lot going on these last couple days as I
finally ended the tour with Peterson
although we're continuing again in the
new year but we taped like five shows in
the last two days we're finishing
seriously strong for the for the end of
the year we got some great stuff coming
but this has taken every other moment of
my life because this is a direct not
only is it related completely to free
speech and everything that I talk about
constantly and what's going on with
these platforms and these companies but
it's also directly related to my
business so just FYI at the moment we've
lost about 500 patrons and that's been
it I think it's around five or six
thousand bucks a month that we've lost
now most of the people have messaged me
and said I'm really sorry Dave I love
what you're doing this is nothing to do
with you the
to stand against patreon now the funny
thing here is that I'm actually at one
level I'm very inspired that these
people are you guys right you guys are
just like you know what [ __ ] this I
can't take this [ __ ] anymore we have we
have known this is coming these these
lines of what is acceptable and what's
not acceptable keep moving and moving
and moving and Sargon I don't know
everything about the guy but if this guy
is the type of person that cannot be on
a platform then half the people I know
probably can't be on a platform and that
may include me and that probably
includes you so we keep letting these
things move again it doesn't matter what
you think about Alex Jones but you take
out one it's not like when they take out
one person they're like ah we got one
person we're good to go let's pack it in
guys let's find a new hobby it's like oh
well who can we keep moving
who can be keep moving can we keep
moving and the thing is when I started
my patreon hangouts today so this is
this is the day that we do the rewards
where I do these small Google Hangouts
with people right before I started you
can look at my last tweet or two tweets
ago Vox that awful steaming pile of poop
that is Vox which is funded to hundreds
of millions of dollars a year yet is
obsessed with a couple youtubers wrote a
piece where they're calling a whole
bunch of us once again of the usual
suspects they're calling a whole bunch
of us alright and reactionary right the
rest of it and it's like man well you
keep doing that and then eventually why
wouldn't these platforms boot us so I
have a vested interest in having this
thing stopped because eventually it's
gonna come for me and by the way if you
like the things I'm talking about it's
probably gonna come for you too
so I'm oddly inspired on some level that
people are kind of standing up and
they're saying we're not gonna put our
money to companies that don't support
what we believe in or at least respect
free speech and whatever else and then
at the same time I'm taking a business
hit so I'm not sure what to do so let me
just throw out just one quick little
promo thing here if you can go to day
brew but not if you can if you'd like to
go to Dave Rubin dot-com slash donate
you can donate there and keep the show
independent we are a hundred percent
independent I am my boss I am the CEO of
this company we are we have several
employees now the morning that this all
went down we just actually flipped one
of our part-timers to a full-timer
I'm super proud of what we've built here
we built a great community beyond just
the conversations we're having all that
I've traveled the world this year and
met thousands and thousands of you guys
it's all good it's all good and if you
want to help us keep it independent and
you're not happy with what's going on on
patreon you can go to Dave Rubin calm
sesh donate you can do a one-time
donation or a monthly donation PayPal
credit card doesn't matter okay so that
I just wanted to say that because a lot
of you guys are asking me I spent the
last couple days really really really
trying to figure out what to do about
this
I wrote a statement that I almost
published where I was going to announce
that I was leaving patreon I was gonna
do something nuts I mean a normal person
a normal person in business doesn't
voluntarily kiss 65 or 70 percent of
their monthly revenue goodbye but I was
gonna do it because I really thought
like we're not gonna get many more of
these moments you know what I mean it's
a little bit like you don't want to
swing too early when something's happen
and you don't want to swing too late you
want to swing right at the right moment
but we don't know when that right moment
is anymore these these bands and these
shadow bands and algorithmic nonsense it
all seems so arbitrary and ridiculous
that we don't know when it is going to
happen you know you mean like it's very
possible that ever that right now
there's a Google engineer watching this
right now going oh man I hope you will
just slip up and say something say the
word that Sargon said so I can give him
the boot too I mean we just don't know
what the hell is going on here but I do
know that the CEO of patreon sat in my
studio and said this is about behavior
and these are about things that happen
on the platform and and either he
changed or he lied to me or he doesn't
know what he's talking about and I'm not
even making this up to throw jack conte
under the bus being like CEO of one of
these companies probably sucks and every
day you're just under assault from
social justice warriors who want to
destroy another human being and by the
way this is permeating society at every
level right now the Oscars can't even
find a freaking host because they had
Kevin Hart and then apparently he said
[ __ ] and now he can't host the Oscars
I mean everything is is just nonsense
and drivel and we must stand up against
it and I think you guys are getting a
little bolder and standing up against it
I meet people who are starting to get
more engaged I think people are
realizing it's coming to all of our
doors
if we don't do it and again as I say
every frickin week I'm just some guy I
don't know why I'm doing this I'm not a
superhero but we've got to get better at
this we've got to get better at
organizing and fighting this anyway what
I've realized is it would not be wise or
make any business sense to just kiss 70%
of my revenue goodbye and hope that a
whole bunch of people are gonna go and
donate on my site I do there's a lot of
things I want to do on that and to fix
things but what I would say is at the
moment if we can migrate as much as many
people from patreon and new people over
to Dave Rubin - donate it will give me
the leverage I need to do what I think
is right
that being said what you can do it or
not do it it's all good either way we'll
figure it out and I'm not sitting here
like cry me a river I want to solve this
problem and I and I can't get into all
the conversations I've had about this
but I but many of the people that that
you know and admire who are who are
friends of mine that have been on the
show and all that they're thinking about
what to do - like everybody is I think I
can say that much everybody is realizing
this is a escalation of this that if we
let this guy go down and we don't make
anything of it it's not about him
specifically but if we let another
person go down who doesn't deserve to go
down it's coming it's coming and it's
getting bolder every time because nobody
stands up to it so we got a stock start
standing up more so I'm happy to take
any of your questions on that I'm happy
to take a whole bunch of questions on on
a series of things and we'll figure it
out I mean look there's there's lots of
options I've had ad agencies reach out
to me in the last couple of days and
they're asking me if I want to start
reading ads on the YouTube show you know
I don't really want to do that I don't
really want to do that but maybe that is
a safer financial route than going fully
fan funded but I love being fan funded
like I'm free I'm truly free you know we
were we get I mean I'll just tell you
guys like we get patreon is our number
one read source we get YouTube breath
which is obviously all over the place
and then we do have ads on our our audio
podcast the only other thing that we've
ever had in terms of revenue you know a
little bit on merch whatever the only
other thing we ever had was we had that
partnership with learn Liberty
for two years which we ended in June
they wanted to continue it actually and
I just felt like we could try some new
things so I am talking some other
nonprofits about maybe doing some other
things outside but you know that's what
our revenue streams are so maybe there
are some other ways we can we can do
some other things one of the silly thing
on revenue just because I think this
will help frame a little bit of this for
you guys so you know we had Shapiro and
Peterson in here on last Friday and the
video as the last I saw has around 1.1
million views it's a two-hour video it's
why I think it's one of the best things
that we've ever done in the studio it's
I think we got the best out of Ben the
best out of Jordan I think we covered
new ground we went deep on religion
talked about differences and
similarities and I thought it was really
excellent it operated it's sort of a
very high bar there were moments where I
had to sort of dumb it down because I
want one I want regular people to be
able to understand these things - anyway
- our video over 1 million views the
average watch time last I saw it was
about 40 minutes which is obscenely high
for YouTube right like think about the
last time you watched a 40 minute video
on YouTube right what do you do you
watch a kid fall down you watch somebody
get hit in the nuts you watch a cat and
then you watch a ten minute chat and
then whatever else you're watching a
little basketball or whatever somebody
playing video games okay that's an
incredible amount of content that people
are watching for a long time that video
last I saw had generated I think around
5,000 bucks so now think about that if
that had been on CNN or just anything on
primetime 2 hours of where a million
people were watching now to give that a
little context NBC Nightly News they
tell you I think averages around 1.4
million views at night so basically that
video got roughly or by the end of this
week let's say we'll have the same
amount that NBC News gets on any given
night think about the revenue that NBC
News generates from all the advertisers
that are they they probably are making
millions of dollars that night that
video made us 5,000 bucks so the
economics of this whole thing are all
out of whack - and I think that that's
also causing some of the tension anyway
that's why we obviously are on patreon
and again I'm not saying any
to cry me a river' I'm just saying it
because I'm trying to be as transparent
as I possibly can be with you guys as
we're at a strange crossroads which is
also sort of funny or odd for me because
this has been such an incredible year I
mean I did about a hundred stops with
Peterson I started doing stand-up again
we're selling out all these clubs I just
got back from a gig at University of
Wyoming 300 great young people
conservatives who are happy to talk
about ideas and when we did the Q&A we
we had people come up first who
disagreed with me so I'm feeling so
great about everything the show's grown
we're gonna cross nine hundred thousand
subscribers today or tomorrow
there's so many good things happening
that it's just great so it's kind of
funny now that we're ending the year on
this odd note relative to the business
which is so relative to the core issues
that we're talking about about
platforming and free speech and anything
else so anyway that's all that I have a
feeling I'm gonna have about a gazillion
questions about all of this stuff so
let's see when is must gonna kick off
his version of YouTube it could it be
called dark tube I don't know you know
I've never been connected with a lot
obviously we're we have a couple
connections in in our world but we need
somebody to get on get in on this you
know I think there's been some chatter
from the billionaire class but it's like
we need you guys if you happen to be a
billionaire and you're watching this
right now
hello you can email me right at babe
Rubin comm contact you'll find it ok I
will follow you to PayPal or anywhere
else the other than patreon just
announced where to go and I'll follow
you you do good work well thank you very
much it's just Dave Rubin com / donate
and you can do monthly you can do
one-time whatever it is what are the IDW
members willing to do about solving the
issue versus hoping someone else will do
it instead fans leaving patreon me too
before the end of the year are taking
action where is the action from our
thought leaders what a great question
right this is what it's all about like
one of the things that I've said
repeatedly over the last year is that I
don't want these conversations just to
remain conversations I want to figure
out how to put these ideas into action
how do we get politicians elected that
that maybe believe in some of these
things how do we get the Democrats to
return to liberalism let's say
which by in turn would then maybe
moderate moderate make the Republicans a
little more moderate something like that
um we're all talking about it I can't I
can't I mean I just can't I can't tell
you the the nature of all of the private
conversations but what I can tell you is
that everyone that you think might be
thinking about this is thinking about it
and trying to figure out what to do and
it's like we all have different
considerations right we all have
different businesses some of us are
professors and authors some of us are on
speaking tours some of us are generating
more revenue YouTube I mean we're all
trying to figure out some of them
already been on patreon at all but but
understand the gravity of the situation
so everyone's trying to figure it out
just try to be patient with us which
sucks - because it's like man the more
patient we are we're just giving room
right we're just giving room for these
guys to come in and swoop down and knock
out the next one and it's like the more
hysterical these these what's acceptable
to be said is so like you know if you
miss gender or dead named I had never
heard this phrase dead named Corey now
if you dead name someone meaning if if a
trans person goes by Alison but their
old name was Andy if you call them Andy
you could be banned on Twitter I mean
these really really really Orwellian
speech codes they could come to get
anybody either because someone's making
a joke or you know in a case of let's
say Shapiro it's like facts don't care
about your feelings I'm gonna say what I
think have related to how many genders
there are or whatever else it is so it's
a mess and I and trust me we're we're
trying we're trying to figure it out
okay um let's see
plans for John McWhorter to come on the
show also will you wear chapstick if I
shipped you some my lips are always
drying can I get some chapstick in here
I'm gonna put on some chapstick right
now little chapstick would be nice
they're a little dry a little dry
alright good so get a little chapstick
in here hey Dave just subscribe to your
website thanks for the critical work
that you do thank very much chapstick
apparently this live stream is brought
to you by Burt's Bees so there you go
alright now I've got
now that moist lips okay there we go
let's see here we go I feel like there's
groupthink in television I hear the
pundits United in one agenda and saying
practically the same thing so are the
heads of studios in charge and the
people on television and thus the people
on television willing to say what they
are told in exchange for money status
fame all right so are the people look I
try not to judge people's motives so I
don't know when you you know it's funny
I was in the gym the other day I never
watched CNN anymore it's just painful
it's just dribble endless Trump Russia
dribble you will not get smarter you
will get dumb or watching this but every
now and again in the gym it's on and
I'll flick the channels and like all
right let me just pause and watch this I
don't know like these people
intentionally ask the stupid questions
do they intentionally conflate and
confuse the issues I don't know are some
people more opportunistic than others
and and just want fame and fortune sure
I guess you know that's probably true
are some people probably not that bright
and maybe that helps them succeed in in
a talking head world that's probably
true too so yeah it's why people are
tuning out of these things no one's
paying attention to these things and in
a way that's why they're they're
cracking down on so many of us I mean
think about why is Vox again today and
it's not the first time they've done it
writing an article that basically is
trying to link me and Shapiro and Lacey
green and and a couple others to the
alt-right it's like you know why they're
doing it cuz they're threatened by the
so Vox which is tuned to you know like
200 million dollars or the VC money is
worried about it but what a bunch of of
upstart
youtubers are doing because you can see
we're getting all the clicks we're
getting all the views we're getting all
the retweets and it's like go look it go
right now go look at I just let me pick
something that's hot but do this test
for me and someone can comment on it and
I'll and I'll read it look at BuzzFeed
or Huffington Post's last ten tweets and
then look at my last ten tweets and tell
me which one has more traction and
there's no doubt that mine do and a
couple of mine are just promotions of
this which isn't the type of thing that
gets a lot of traction but I guarantee
you if
at all those up mine we way way way way
so they've had it with other interesting
people don't think like they do getting
clicks and views and making people up
conversation and and having people be
enlightened instead of drilled down to
the point of stupidity oh yeah it's a
mess
admittedly you have learned and grown
from speaking to a variety of people you
said that your interview with Larry
elder change your viewpoint about
systemic racism has another guest
fundamentally changed another point of
view that's a really good question you
know you know when I came back last year
last September when I did that
off-the-grid thing not this past summer
but the summer before that was the first
time where I did the August completely
off the grid and when I came back I had
said that although I know he's sort of
at least for the last couple years I
thought of myself as an atheist that I
didn't really like the term I didn't
like the word for me it doesn't really
capture what I am because it's not have
a sort of lack of belief but I I do
believe in something that I can't quite
explain exactly what it is so I just
didn't want to use the term atheist to
explain it any more I can tell you that
in the last year having these
conversations with Shapiro and Peterson
and I just had a great conversation
yesterday it'll be up next week excuse
me with Bishop Baron who's been on the
show who's from the archdiocese here in
LA and with Rabbi Wolfie who's the rabbi
at Temple Sinai in Beverly Hills we had
a great conversation which I thought
would be perfect to do right between
Hanukkah and Christmas by the way I also
had yesterday I had Imam Tweedy on that
will be up next week so my last three
interviews have been with a rabbi a
rabbi a priest and an imam walk into a
gay podcasters garage there's an old
joke but I would say I've been moved on
the look this is all I could end up
doing three hours on this thing but I've
been moved on on a certain value of
religion it doesn't mean everyone has to
be religious I'm not religious but a
certain value in belief of sort of an
unmoved mover kind of thing you know
I've seen Jordan
in these hundred or so shows that we've
done together really stretch his
knowledge on this and really explain the
value of these stories and that there
are certain ancient truths that can't be
that not every truth that exists can be
empirically proven or that science and
logic alone aren't enough to explain all
of the driving forces that make us human
and make us love and hate and all of
those other things so I would say that's
one that I'm sort of evolving on which
is actually kind of cool and it's and
it's also like a very much an
affirmation of you know that I'm doing
something good for a living because I
don't mean this to be sappy or sarcastic
even but like I sit across from people
every day that I can learn something
from and if I can just keep my mind open
enough to learn something or even hear
something that I disagree with and then
that makes my belief reinforced
afterwards that's pretty cool too so I
would say I'm I'm evolving on some of
that stuff I think it's a great
conversation I think the fact that so
many people are thinking about it that
we can do videos on the nature of
reality and and the nature of truth and
can you get value out of fact alone the
people the fact that people care about
this and not just a couple people but
millions and millions of people care
about it I mean that's that's pretty
awesome do you ever get confused with
David Rubin the author also do you have
a book in you so first off that's
hilarious I was on Tucker Carlson last
night and her before me was David Rubin
who is a mayor a former mayor in Israel
so a lot of people were confused because
I was like copy on Tucker Carlson
tonight and then they tune in and
there's a guy David Rubin older guy you
know white hair in Israel that was not
me also do have a book in you so yeah
yeah you know I'm just gonna do it
we signed my book deal finally it's with
a big publisher I'm super psyched I
don't know that I can fully say
everything but I'm writing it right now
it is going to be the most difficult
thing that I have ever done that is very
obvious I'm trying to get seriously
deeply personal and not just political
but the deal is done the advances has
hit the checking account and and I'm
psyched to to do something
I think we'll be will be real and
relevant and it'll be out months before
the 2020 election I want to get you know
cuz then it's like they're just gonna
put our political book after political
book it's just gonna be awful so I think
it's gonna be out in Surrey in the
spring probably March or April of 2020 I
know that seems like a long time from
now I have to have the manuscript in by
August first and it just takes time
it seems weird in this world of like
such quick stuff happening all the time
and live streams and all this other
stuff but yeah it'll it'll be out then
and I'm psyched and it's gonna be a lot
of work but you know what else am i
doing
are you ever worried that your platform
on YouTube can be completely taken away
yeah I mean yeah like how can i watch
the tea leaves change how can i watch
Sargon be booted from patreon and other
people be booted from Twitter and people
be kicked off YouTube and some people
get reinstated and how can I watch all
of these things happen and not think oh
man it could become for me maybe not
even cuz the signing I said what if I
had a guest on who went on a crazy
racist tirade well we know what Vox
would write about it we know a BuzzFeed
would write about it and then eventually
we know what the trolls would do and
they'd be flagging flagging flagging
flagging then eventually YouTube may be
like you know what enough of this
headache so that's why there is a
technological answer to this maybe
there's a blockchain based video site
coming up maybe people need to use more
crypto to support the creators that they
like but I think whatever you guys can
do in your life to fight back whether
that's talking about these ideas or
protesting if you do it within the
confines of the law or going to or not
using services if you don't like them
which is why as I said earlier I'm
watching my patreon money drop and I'm
kind of inspired by it because it's like
at least you guys are doing something
and by the way some people are going to
my said they're not just abandoning me
altogether but you're gonna loot you
know you know how it is online it's like
you're doing one thing next thing you
knew and ten other things are looking at
another video and like you just forget
so you're like oh I cancelled this I let
me go over to Dave Rubin calm but then
by the time you get there you already
playing video games or something and you
just forget it it's just it's just how
it is
so it's Dave Rubin calm slash donate but
of course I'm worried about all of those
things I think we don't have an
organized voice we don't have a sensible
plan fully yet I mean I think there's a
lot of discussion about what should
happen and how do we fight this thing
but I don't think we've solved it yet
and we got a lot of work to do do you
get criticized by the LGBT community for
associating what they're interviewing
those of faiths that disagree with
homosexuality so yeah I don't know what
the LGBT community is it's funny when
people talk about the black community or
the LGBT community I mean that's the
type of collectivism that I don't like
because it within those communities of
course you're gonna have a truly diverse
group of people meaning all sorts of
people think differently you're not
gonna believe this but black people
often have different thoughts that have
nothing to do with the color of their
skin and gay people often have different
thoughts that have nothing to do with
their sexuality I'm not I'm not
commenting on you specifically person
who asked me this question but but I do
it too sometimes I'll say the community
that I'm like what what does that really
mean you know you can get general trends
let's say out of community yeah I get
[ __ ] from you know did you see this
article and Deadspin the other day there
was a title the title of the article was
gay conservatives should shut the [ __ ]
up
think about that for a second the title
of the piece that was tweeted out gay
conservatives should shut the [ __ ] up
these are a supposedly the tolerant
people and B these are supposedly the
pro gay people right these are the
lefties where we're tolerant and we love
gays you know I love minorities but they
don't and you really need to understand
that they love you if you bow that's it
they don't love you because you're gay
they love you as long as you'll behave
they're not for women to say you're for
women everyone's for women it's
meaningless to say you're for women I'm
want everyone on this earth to be
treated equally under the law and live
with a sense of dignity and hopefully
find something that they're passionate
about and live the best life they can
live I'm for women in that I want women
to be part of that but to say you're for
women are the women who run the women's
march are they for nikki Haley who I
think is a spectacular woman she's the
governor of South Carolina who was the
US representative at the UN for the last
two years and maybe one day she'll be
present in the United States she happens
to be a brown woman and that she's
Indian but she's a Republican are you
for Nikki Haley you're not for nikki
Haley you're not for Sarah Huckabee
Sanders you're not for women who
disagree so to say you're four groups is
actually ridiculous related to the
gaping well it's interesting because
it's like I never get not that anyone
cares about the Cade press or The
Advocate or out or any of those things
anymore nobody reads them anymore but
it's like you'd think that maybe they'd
write an article about me because I am
openly gay and I'm doing this and people
seem to care about it right daily wire
just did really cool interview with me
that I was I was really happy to do so
it's not for lack that I wouldn't want
to talk to these people but outdoor
advocate I forget which one about two or
three years ago wrote a piece that Peter
teal who's also openly gay who spoke at
the Republican National Convention
before Trump accepted the nomination he
went up there he said I'm a proud gay
man and got a standing ovation at the
Republican National Convention that was
very underreported by the way he can't
imagine why
but outer advocate wrote an article
saying Peter Thiel is not gay because
they've decided that your sexuality is
in your sexuality it's how you behave
how if you were in line with their
political lives then you can be gay but
he's not gay because he votes for people
that we don't like I mean think how
that's actually offensive like it's hard
to offend me but that's actually events
it what I can tell you is this which is
much more inspiring than what I've just
said is that in the last year or so
where I've done a hundred stops and we
were in probably 15 different countries
and why you know people coming up to me
in Helsinki and Stockholm on the street
and Amsterdam at a store and we're and
everywhere in Kansas City and in Orlando
and in San Diego that gay people come up
to me all the time and they'll be like
what happened to the case we used to be
fun we used to be edgy we used to care
about music and dance and being the
other and it been for the pain for a
pain right it was pain that brought that
because a community that wasn't treated
equally because these people could not
get married often that that internal
whatever that
turtle pain caused great art caused
great humor all of those things and
music and all of that
well now we're equal and maybe some of
that pain is gone which i think is
actually good because now we can be
treated as shittily as everybody else
but when you're not equal under the law
than you do deserve to be equal under
the law and you might act out
differently so I think people are now
seeing that as the progressives have
sort of infiltrated the gay community
that gays aren't that fun anymore
so I think a lot of gays are breaking I
think it's a little bit also of what
Candis Owens has done with the black
community so to speak so there's
interesting things happening right now
I'd like to pose the same question you
posed to Brigitte Gabriel what has been
the personal cost for what you do well
first let me just say that mostly this
is great it's mostly great this was the
most rewarding year in my life for sure
being part of the Petersons tour getting
back into stand-up as I said meeting so
many people you know after the after the
show is we do a meet and greet
so Jordan doesn't meet-and-greet and I
do a separate meet and greet and
sometimes people go to both and usually
about 50 people or so come to my
meet-and-greet and we get in a small
room and it's about a half hour and I
get to shoot the [ __ ] and meet you guys
people give me gifts and wanna hug me
well first up no one can ever believe
I'm real because you guys only see me on
YouTube but they want to poke me often
but people say all these great things
and it's so nice so validating know that
you guys are out there and it's all
kinds of people from all walks of life
and all that and it's really fun and I
also do those meet and greets after my
stand-up shows and it's totally fun so
that's all validating and great and good
and you know we've built a great
business here and you know ironically
the day that we found out this stupid
patreon thing was happening we had just
flipped one of our part-timers to a
full-timer so there's a lot of good
things happening we've got a lot of
plans for next year there's gonna be a
lot more travel I think we're in do more
shows on the road whole bunch of stuff I
would say the cost part well it's not
fun reading these articles right like so
if Fox is like Rubens party all right
and then and then you know 20 blue check
you know 3,000 follower verified Twitter
people tweet it out it's like it's not
fun seeing that but it's like you guys
are desperate and that occurs thing so I
don't really care about that that much
anymore but I do think about it
sometimes
you know I get recognized places and I
could be at a restaurant where someone
has read one of those articles about me
and they could be looking at me like
Reuben zoom you see that guy over there
like he's a white supremacist or some
just completely bananas something like
so that part's not fun and I think
there's probably been costs there's
probably been some business or
professional costs but I'm very happy
with what I'm doing I think we're
building something so cool and even for
the the patreon part of this that is now
a problem we'll figure it out we'll
figure it out like you didn't beat me
yet you know I've taken big risks in the
past when we got on patreon in the first
place
me and David and Amira we've all quit
our jobs left our health insurance the
whole thing to join on patreon just to
see if it would work and nobody really
was on patreon in the political space
now everyone's on there but a time it
was mostly video gamers and I was like
let's try it and we did try it and it
worked and it has basically been the
engine of the show for the last three
years or so so this time around when
this thing happened I really was like
like there was a part of me that wanted
to do something crazy like I still have
that in me I'm 42 but I guess I still
got a little bit of like a crazy 21 year
old in me and I was like I should just
cancel patreon we'll figure it out you
know like it's not like I want to stand
up for something and and then like cop
you know then I realize have got
employees now I've got different the
business has different expenses and
things like that you just can't nobody
and nobody in their right mind just
gives up all that bread but we will
figure it out and as I said if I can
migrate enough people from patreon or we
can get enough people off our new people
to donate at the site again it's Dave
Rubin comm so that's donate I'm sorry
from being a televangelist here we'll do
it we'll do it I want to send them a
message and I want to coordinate some of
this by the way with some of the other
IDW crew so hang tight on some of that
stuff is there anything you'd like to
refute that has been said about you by
your critics refute I mean yeah well I
guess I'm not you know come on of the
things that I see from a lot of these
whatever these beyond at critics that's
even that's being giving them a nice
term was that I was funded by the Koch
brothers I am not funded by the Koch
brothers
what these wizards are just trying to
say is that learn liberty was fun learn
liberty that we had the partnership with
which by the way every episode of every
show that we ever did with them I said
this episode is it just what I say in
partnership with our friends that learn
Liberty
so it wasn't something that I was hiding
years ago I think one of the Koch
brothers gave some money to learn
liberty through George Mason University
to an organization called the Institute
for Humane studies or something anyway
none of that even matters all sorts of
people you out there person right now
you probably donate to to nonprofits too
right people donate to nonprofits
thousands and thousands of people donate
to Institute for Humane studies and
learn liberty was just one of their
projects but anyway that was in like
2012 or something I didn't start working
with them until 2016 anyway so people
say he's funded by the Koch brothers and
it's like I'm not funded by the Koch
brothers actually the person who funded
our year of sponsorship which I said
when I've been working with them anymore
and it was a wonderful partnership and
that is no way throwing them under the
bus I loved everybody at learn Liberty
they let us do whatever we want I never
nobody ever said say this talk about
this think about this anything like that
they gave us great professors we had
great shows we did that president's
weekly thing last year with them so it
was it was wonderful partnership I just
wanted to kind of think about some other
things as I said they wanted to continue
it I was like let me see if I can figure
out some other interesting things we've
had a nice run with it um but people
like you're funded by the Koch prize I
was like actually the person who funded
us is an anonymous woman I only know
it's a woman because they told me it's a
woman so if you want to write her a
handwritten note you could write ma'am
so I get right ma'am
you know on a note to an anonymous
person who happened to give the funds
that funded us anyway whatever you know
I don't need I don't mind critics if
you're look when people say well Rueben
you know it's funny people will say
Reubens too much like Larry King well
I've had Larry King in here just a
couple weeks ago he is a friend and a
mentor and the fact that he even thinks
I'm halfway decent at this is the
greatest compliment ever so I would say
the Larry and the if you look at the
breadth of his work is probably the
greatest interviewer of all time so if
your criticism is I'm too much like
Larry King
that would be like criticizing Kobe
Bryant and saying you're too much like
Michael Jordan like that's pretty good
that's pretty good so I don't mind
criticism if you want to criticize the
way I question
somebody for a follow-up that maybe I
missed or some of that stuff it's all
good I'm not perfect and you know I'll
always get better I hope I always get
better I'll at least always try to get
better but it's when people just like
lie about what I say and and selectively
at Eclipse and obsess over me like
there's there's like a crew of people
that are just endlessly obsessed over
what I say and it's like you're not even
care anymore it's like what are you
doing like if you wake up and think Dave
Rubens the biggest problem in the world
holy [ __ ] the patriarchy must not be
that bad
cuz this is the worst you got you got to
make videos about me all day so yeah
whatever um let's see all right so one
well this is a great one what is the
goal or where is the group and court
headed I'll hold that one to the end
because that's a great question let's
see here
just check twitter huffington post and
they have one tweet with 400 retweets
today everything else is significantly
lower engagement yeah I assume that all
of my I mean many of my tweets now at
this point get into the tens of
thousands of retweets and favorites and
all that and it's like they can't have
regular people getting more engagement
than them even though they buy all their
followers and the rest of it Deadspin is
a sports site allegedly they're a sports
site I did not know that um let's see
when do you think that sports and
entertainment sites will finally figure
out that we don't want politics in our
entertainment they seem to be losing
market share but they just seem to go it
out great question
nobody wants to watch ESPN to hear about
endless politics and this is what they
keep giving us and I think Travis Clay
Travis calls it woke Center and it's
like man that's shit's boring just
endlessly talking about politics
everywhere so we have no spaces where we
can just be people watch a game together
or just be people who play a video game
together or shoot hoops together or
whatever it's like if we don't have
those spaces we've got nothing left
which is ironic yeah at a some level for
where I'm at because I've said this
before but in a way I'm less interested
in politics specifically than I've ever
been there's this cultural thing
happening right now that's intertwined
with technology and entertainment and
politics that's what I'm interested in
politics alone about what's happening in
the Senate today or or Nancy Pelosi
might stay on as the lead
indefinitely or Trump met with it's like
that that all just seems like theatre to
me at this point and there's just
something much more important happening
and that's what I want to talk about but
I also want to talk about the bigger
ideas which is why I just had a rabbi a
priest and an imam in okay let's see um
[Music]
who oh man there's a lot of good stuff
here will you ever invite jack conte
back on to lie to our faces again you
know what let me figure out what's going
on here with the patreon situation and
maybe I would offer him the chair to sit
in again at the end of the day unless he
truly changed then he lied to me
he said this manifest observable
behavior thing he said on platform both
of those things turned out to be a lie
so I don't need to give him a platform
again and I'm not thrilled with what's
going on with patreon it as I said we
can migrate enough people over we will
make a move and and we've got some other
plans by the way that I just can't get
into everything at the moment in front
of all of you good people okay let's see
do you think that the left has a
difficult time articulating and
defending their views many of your
guests Peterson Shapiro Shapiro Brigitte
Gabriel have been able to defend their
abuse factually for example using
judeo-christian values I'm sincerely
trying to find opposing views but I have
yet to see a civil interview or bet or
yet or sorry we're better yet a debate
where it's explained with facts not
feelings and defense of their position
well I don't want to say it's impossible
and by the way you know I still have I
still have good friends and some of the
IDW crew like the weinstein brothers and
sam they think they all still identify
as lefty so I don't think it's
impossible but those guys too really are
on the outs right so it's like you know
I when I do stand-up I usually bring one
of the IDW people with me and it's a
surprise so I've brought when we were in
Salt Lake City I brought Jordan on stage
which was awesome and we just joked
around for an hour and the crowd was
going bananas now that really was an
incredible show if any of you were at
that Salt Lake City shows amazing
I've brought Brett on I've brought Eric
on I brought Brett and Eric together I
brought christina hoff sommers on I
brought Michael Shermer two weeks ago at
the improv in San Jose and look I think
it's getting
increasingly hard to find lefties that
will talk honestly and look there yes
are there some youtubers to funny this
is where they'll go but there are five
youtubers who demand to debate you all
the time well you keep talking [ __ ]
about me and lying about me it's like
I'm not gonna do it I'm just not gonna
do it I'm just playing a different game
than they're playing and they can play
whatever game they want that's fine and
I know that by just talking [ __ ] about
me you get clicks so alright enjoy your
clicks it's fine it's getting
increasingly hard to do and the evidence
for that would be look it's when I do
these stand-up shows I mean most of my
audience at this point it's sort of like
I think it's pretty split it's hard to
say you know it's sort of we've got some
old-school liberals in the crowd let's
say we've got some libertarians in the
crowd we've got some conservatives and
the card occasionally there's a couple
sort of more lefties but that you know
it's a pretty big split maybe if
anything it leans a little bit more
libertarian or conservative which would
be absolutely fine with me by the way
and it's like I bring on you know let's
say a Brett or an Eric and they talk
about how they're Brett less Brett's a
good example I bring on Brett he talks
about how he's always been a progressive
he still considers himself a progressive
all the innings and the audience loves
him and he talks about reasons that he
talks about differences of opinion and
the audience still loves him try to
imagine that happening at another way
imagine a comedian that was a big lefty
progressive bringing on a speaker who
was a conservative to a lefty crowd how
would they treat that conservative the
reason you can't think of any evidence
of that is because they would treat them
very poorly so look this was even when I
was at the University of Wyoming a
couple of days ago and and I did not
even say this earlier I've been talking
to the camera all day so I can't
remember I just said this or if I just
said it's good people before me but
people before this was I did this great
talk where I talked about the
differences between liberals and
conservatives to a group of about 300
kids at University City Wyoming expunged
er by turning-point us a young college
conservative group and then at the end
well first off like you know the kids
are thrilled that I was there and great
applause and everything but when we do
the Q&A they specifically ask for people
that disagree with
first I mean that there is such a
richness right now happening especially
with young conservatives and
libertarians don't dismiss it it's not
getting picked up anywhere in the
mainstream media because they don't like
that narrative they like only the woke
narratives those are the tolerant the
tolerant people who keep telling gay
people to shut the [ __ ] up and black
people to stay in their Lane those are
the tolerant people don't you know whoo
okay um have you made plan B should you
find yourself off YouTube when it man
it's depressing that these questions are
even coming in but I mean this is the
point this is the point of the the
Sargon situation it's like we have to
figure all these things out yes I have
had a zillion meetings this week in a
zillion different places and the
meetings will continue we're trying to
figure out all of the firewalls we're
trying to figure out how to make sure
funding doesn't get cut we're trying to
figure out all this stuff I can't fully
get into all of it now but we're trying
to figure it out and I appreciate the
questions when's your next la show so
Jordan and I were just at the LA Orpheum
downtown which was awesome I brought
Shapiro on as a surprise guest crowd
went crazy he gave me a cupcake on stage
because you know you won't bake me a gay
cake so he gave me a cupcake it was very
exciting which then I tweeted a picture
of that out and then just the usual the
tolerant left these oh look at this
disgusting display Rubin is so pathetic
for even standing there with Shapiro and
it's like you know what I can stand
there with someone I disagree with on
something even something pretty damn
fundamental and enjoy it and enjoy a
moment on stage of laughter with with
3,000 people that are cheering and
screaming despite our differences but
you guys are the tolerant ones remind me
again tolerant
so my next la shows we've got two things
I'm at the Irvine improv with a
particularly big IDW guest that's in
Orange County on January 30th at the
Irvine improv you don't want to miss it
I don't want to say who it is just yet
that's the vine improv and then on I
think January 9th I'm at the Ontario
California improv I'm pretty sure that's
the date you can go to Dave Rubin comm
slash events for that then I've got
three gigs with Peterson in in January
and then we head off to to Australia in
February unfortunately
gonna miss the New Zealand events I got
I do a family thing in February that's
an annual thing that I really don't want
to miss so I'm gonna miss New Zealand
which of course I would love to go to
New Zealand and have some New Zealand
lanta my lamb I'm having lamb for dinner
tonight um okay
[Music]
ESPN just announced that they
miscalculated about being woke sports
and clay covered it took ESPN about a
decade to admit their mistake but I
would still expect SJW thought to
percolate through well I would love to
know what that means they admitted it
meanings it's they issue a statement
saying we're not gonna keep doing this I
think they're on there they're crumbling
no matter what you know it's like the
ship has sailed you you if you're gonna
infect your company with social justice
which is not about being social nor
about attaining justice it will it will
cause you to have a problem and a
long-term problem look we're well now I
have to figure out what we're doing but
we're hiring right now and I tweeted out
something that said I'm hiring something
to the effect of like I'm hiring only on
skill and expertise I don't care what
gender you are I don't care what skin
colour you are I don't care what
sexuality you are and obviously I'm I'm
like you know playing a joke on this
stupidity but imagine if I did care
about those things wouldn't that imagine
if I was looking at the resumes and I
was like well that's a black lesbian
we're gonna put her give her more of a
chance than this this qualified other
person or this is a trans whatever and
this poor straight white guy well sure
he's been in the business for 20 years
he's got incredible reviews and blah
blah but he shouldn't get the job what
would that make any sense these are the
people that are trying to Institute
racism into the system the system now
raised Lee works do what you want and
does that mean that there might be some
HR people out there who are racist yes
there might be but is that the
government's decision to figure out who
should work where and how we both I
guess that's what a lot of people seem
to want these days okay um let's see I
don't see any other classical liberal
doing what you're doing which is having
conversation and explorative
conversations with people of different
viewpoints you're very successful is it
indicative of a hunger in our society to
have these
Russians so why aren't more liberals
following suit I asked specifically
about liberals because there are many
conservative voices talking even while
being centered you know sensory you know
that's an interesting question look yes
there's a lot of conservative people
doing something sort of similar to this
I suppose so you know Shapiro's out
there with an interview show and Crowder
does something and there's you know more
people on CR TV and back at the blaze
and like that sort of thing all from
sort of a right perspective now maybe
that's because they've all been pushed
there because they don't get any
mainstream coverage where if you turn on
almost every news channel not only CNN
MSNBC obviously but you know you watch
ABC News or NBC News or CBS News it's
balls these are all lefties like do you
think any of these people vote
Republican or any of these people are
conservatives actually some of them are
probably secretly conservative but they
never even mitt it to their friends and
they're getting there you know Karma's a
[ __ ] but I think that probably is
something to do with it why aren't there
more liberals doing it I don't maybe it
is the facts over feelings thing that
people on the Left maybe because they
they go by their heart perhaps more than
their brain so you don't have to think a
problem through you just have to feel
something so I want to help poor people
let's throw money at them that that
feels good like oh I care about poor
people I want to give them money give
them things like now I can walk away and
feel good I don't even really think
about it cuz the government really did
it I just took I just took money from
other people and gave it to these people
I feel good about it I'm a nice person
look at me I'm a nice person I go to
nice parties oh no what did you do well
I didn't do anything but the government
a candidate who raised taxes so that
they could give money to poor people now
if you were to say to them well you know
these programs often don't work you keep
people in sort of indentured servitude
people don't get off welfare all of
these things they get very upset because
they don't want have to think things
through because they like their heart
more than they like their brain or that
or they operate via the heart more than
the brain I try to do a little bit of
both I would say I'm not that suck I'm
not emotional I'm not that worked up or
something like that I don't know I also
I guess it has also something to do with
why I do it this way it's like something
happened that I didn't expect which was
I was talking about the left from a
leftist perspective from a progressive
perspective and suddenly I was getting
an endless amount of hate from the left
which I guess I could have expected I
thought it was a little weird but I was
like oh I'm talking about free speech
I'm talking about some of these issues
that you guys should care about but you
hate me all right that's fine that
wasn't necessarily that surprising was a
little odd but not that surprising the
thing that was surprising was that
suddenly all of these evil conservatives
that the media would make you think are
all racists and bigots and all these
libertarians who are maniacs and all
this other stuff they have only been
welcoming I'm telling you I am meeting
the nicest people I get emails from the
middle of the country from Christian
conservatives that never heard a liberal
not talk down to them that that it's
funny people say oh I'll see Rubens
enabling the far-right it's like
actually I'm getting emails from people
that are becoming often more liberal
from listening to these conversations so
you know it's just a certain amount of
hysteria it's right all right we got
four minutes to go let's see I'll do
I'll do two more
oh I'm local and I'd love to work for
you info on where to submit a resume we
have so many freaking resumes to go
through but you can send it to
I think it's jobs at Rubin report com
and if that doesn't work just go to
contact at or just go to Rubin record
comm slash contact and you can submit
there but I think it's jobs at Rubin
report com
let's see Dave when you appear on Fox
News to any of the hosts such as Tucker
Carlson joke off-camera about you having
your own show on their network well
first time I can tell you I really like
Tucker the two that I know the most are
the two guys that I do their shows the
most Greg Gutfeld I really know the most
in Easton he's just a just a good guy
we've got a couple differences don't
matter but I've enjoyed going out
drinking with them in New York City and
he's just he's a nice guy and he's funny
and he's and he loves being like sort of
ancillary part of the IDW in a way cuz
he's mainstream but they did on the five
the other day they did they're people of
the year and he he was like he's like
Rueben Peterson Shapiro you know
Weinstein that thought I thought it's
like I don't know the other hosts have
any freaking clue who we are but like he
just is like kind of having fun with
this whole thing so I really like Greg
Tucker I know a little bit not as well
as as Greg but I really like Tucker you
know usually when I
Tucker I think except for once or twice
we've done it like I was on Tucker
yesterday and we do it the satellite so
I just go to a little studio here in LA
it's like a little box it's like half
the size in my studio and there's just a
camera in front of you and actually
what's weird this is just a little TV
thing they often put the the monitor so
you can see yourself right beneath you
but it's on like a two-second delay so
the first time I ever did those things I
think it was on HLN years ago it's
really bizarre because you're hearing
someone talk to you but you're seeing
their lips move in a different way and
it's really hard so now I always have to
shut the shut the video feed nobody's
really joked to me about that I mean I
can I can't tell you every little thing
that's going on but like I'm getting all
sorts of crazy offers that's also why
the patreon thing is weird it's like why
is this happening right now like I want
to stay fan funded I really do I want to
be my own boss I don't want to have to
change anything we're doing in in
drastic ways but we got to figure out
the patreon solution but if enough
people go to dave rubin dot-com / donate
you know we'll keep keep on keepin on
okay there's a zillion more questions
here we'll catalogue some of these
because I see there's a lot of a lot of
good stuff here and I'm sorry I couldn't
get to all of it but the last question
which I hit on before which is what is
the goal or where is the Rubin report
headed well look we just had a great
year as I said we're we're gonna crap
crash nine hundred thousand subscribers
today or tomorrow and that's despite the
fact that tons of you come up to me in
real life and keep telling me that you
keep getting unsubscribed YouTube says
you're a bot or you're a Russian troll
and you don't know what you're doing but
the growth of the channel has been great
I think the content that we're doing you
know one of the things that I was afraid
of during the Petersons tour was I was
coming back you know often I'd be
traveling for two or three weeks I'd
come back and we'd have to do you know
three shows in a day and it's one you
know one show I'm sharp as hell two
shows I'm pretty damn sharp third show
I'm kind of like it's a lot of
information to take in and especially if
I was jet-lagged or something I was
really concerned that the quality of the
interviews was going to suffer I
actually think what we've done this this
fall starting with when Shapiro
interviewed me and then the next week
being Peter Thiel and then we did you
know we did the obviously the Petersons
Shapiro thing this interview that I just
did with rabbi opium Bishop Aaron
that'll be up the thing with Imam - ET
de saint
that we put up this week by the way with
ko eval threes just is just great
get to know this girl if you don't know
her what a freakin what a wonder and I'm
just like a little sparkle of joy and
and someone who knows the ideas and
isn't afraid to say what she thinks just
just spectacular so I was really worried
though that that the show was gonna
suffer because of the tour but I really
don't think it did but my one regret
which I mentioned in the live stream
last month is that I don't do to do the
direct messages as much anymore because
we just we don't have the time and also
because we're stocking episodes so
sometimes I taped three in a row
the dm's usually are about what's going
on that week so it's hard to tape at
three weeks in advance but I've been
trying to do a few more of these live
streams you know I did one right before
the election and right after the
election I think I was in UK for one of
them Oslo for the other and we'll keep
doing those things and I think when we
get back eventually to a little more of
a schedule we'll get back to do doing
more of those I think what's gonna
happen in the next year is look we're
gonna figure out a little bit of the
business stuff I think that these issues
that we've been tracking related to free
speech and tech and the rest of it
they're gonna keep ramping up and who
the hell knows what's coming next
like the Sargon thing is a major move
and blind so I don't know what's gonna
come next but we're gonna keep building
this thing and I feel great about I feel
great about the conversations we're
having I feel great about the people
that I'm meeting I feel great about the
business for building I think it's gonna
it's gonna go up on steroids we're gonna
continue the tour with Peterson I'm
gonna do more stand-up than I did this
year it was like I got dragged back in I
didn't even want to do it but now I'm
having fun with it so that's great I'm
gonna write my book or continue writing
my book I should say and we're just
gonna keep going and going and going and
then I don't know when we're gonna rest
but and was resting for us right now so
so that's pretty good and yeah and
that's it so anyway this is this sort of
a bit of an odd livestream I suppose
because there's a lot going on in all
sorts of different ways but as I try to
always say on the patreon day when I
talks in small groups I'm genuinely I'm
humbled and honored by your support and
if you don't support financially just
sharing the videos and telling your
friends about this stuff and you know
people coming up to me and Whole Foods
and the rest of it it's like we're doing
something good
keep doing it it can be exhausting at
times I could probably use like a good
night's sleep you know but like it's all
good it's all good so uh I think you're
gonna really dig Monday show with the
rabbi and the bishop
we've got Imam - IDI before the years
out and I know that might be we might be
holding that one I'm actually not sure
and what else
oh we're gonna do a year-end clip show
with some of my favorite moments that'll
be up the week Christmas and yeah some
other cool stuff so enjoy the season
everybody Happy Holidays hope you had a
Happy Hanukkah hope ya gonna have a
Merry Christmas and oh I will be in
Florida so I do have one last gig I'll
be at the turning point student action
summit I'll be there with Peterson's
gonna be there and Kyle shoes gonna be
there in Candice and Charlie and gutfeld
is gonna be there and Prager and a few
other people so if you happen to be in
West Palm Beach I'm gonna be speaking
there on the 19th yeah swing on by come
say hi see what's going on but I really
I thank you guys for your support all
year we got a couple more shows coming
out so if you're not and alright I think
I'm gonna go have some dinner alright
thanks guys